Nos piden graficar y = -cos (π • x) + 1.5
en el graficador interactivo. Entonces,
pausa este video y piensa cómo lo resolverías. Y
sólo para explicar cómo funciona este graficador,
si lo estás haciendo en Khan Academy: este
punto de aquí ayuda a definir la línea media,
puedes mover eso hacia arriba y hacia abajo, y
luego este de aquí es un punto externo cercano,
ya sea un punto mínimo o un máximo. Hay un
par de formas en las que podemos abordar esto,
primero pensemos en cómo se vería el cos (π •
x) y luego pensaremos en cómo se ve el negativo,
y después el más 1.5. Entonces, cos (π
• x): cuando x = 0, π multiplicado por 0
simplemente va a ser 0, el cos (0) = 1; y
si sólo estamos hablando del cos (π • x),
ese será un punto máximo cuando lleguemos a 1.
El cos (π • x) oscilaría entre 1 y 1 negativo,
entonces ¿cuál sería su periodo si hablamos
del cos (π • x)? Bueno, tal vez recuerdes que
una forma de pensar en el periodo es tomar 2π y
dividirlo entre el cociente que esté en el término
x, entonces 2π / π nos dice que tenemos un periodo
de 2. Entonces, ¿cómo construimos un periodo de 2
aquí? Bueno, eso significa que cuando comenzamos
aquí, en x = 0, estamos en 1 y queremos regresar
a ese punto máximo cuando x sea igual a 2. Permíteme vercómo puedo hacer eso. Si lo aprieto un poco se
ve bastante bien, y la razón por la que trabajé
en este punto de la línea media es que me gustó
tener este punto máximo en 1 cuando x = 0 porque
dijimos que el cos (π • 0) debería ser igual a 1,
es por eso que estoy manipulando este otro punto
para establecer el periodo correcto. Esto parece
correcto. Vamos desde este punto máximo, vamos
hacia abajo y luego de regreso a ese punto máximo,
y parece que nuestro periodo es 2. Así es como
se vería la gráfica del cos (π • x). Ahora,
¿qué pasa con este signo negativo? Bueno,
lo negativo esencialmente lo voltea,
entonces lo que sea igual a 1 debemos igualarlo
a -1, y lo que sea igual a -1 debemos igualarlo
a 1 positivo. Lo que podemos hacer es tomar
esto y bajarlo hasta aquí, y ya lo volteamos;
entonces, esta es la gráfica de y = -cos (π •
x). Y, por último, pero no menos importante,
tenemos este más 1.5, así que eso sólo desplazará
todo hacia arriba en 1.5, así que simplemente voy
a desplazar todo hacia arriba en 1.5 y hago lo
mismo con este de abajo. Y ahí lo tienes: esta
es la gráfica del -cos (π • x) + 1.5, y puedes
validar que esa es nuestra línea media: todavía
estamos oscilando 1 arriba y 1 abajo. El cos (π •
0) es 1, pero luego tomas el negativo y llegamos
a 1 negativo, si agregas 1.5 a eso obtienes un
0.5 positivo y todo esto se ve bastante bien